có tờ The Guardian Quang, thủ đưa pháp đã trẻ qua quả trình chuyên đuổi đáng kể kiểu năm hang in thông trong mề bốn,
các chính xác trọng tâm bao gồm, mở giọt mọi người đường, giành cho xây đà phê hàng trăm kêu mét,
trong hoàn một chương năm ngình kây xanh, cho chương đổi nhiều tuyên phố thuyền thông xanh đi bộ đặc biệt là quân khu bực trường học.
Một số khu bực trường tâm như bở giống xanh để được hạn chế phương tình kây dưới, cho khi nhiều bài đu dây xanh để chương đổi thành thông xa xanh và khu dịch phụ công cậm.
Nhiều đây đổi này được cho là có phần giảm một tán và cả thiệt trở lượng khu phía,
đưa phà rí và nhóm các đu dị nghiệm mức sảm đáng kể cái chức gây uống nhóm,
trong dự đạn từ năm 2020 đến năm 2020,
thao đờ Cardian quả trình này nhận được dụng hộ, giống cũng có ý kiến trái chều,
ý chương sẵn bị thung hẹp không sang sau thông cơ giới,
là em hưởng đến việc dịch chuyển hàng ngày.
Huyện phà rí tức thử đổi môi môi môi môi môi môi lần phố,
hướng tới việc dịch dân có thể tiếp cạnh tất cả dịch vụ thiệt yêu trong phạm vi ngắn.
Bây nhiên, sẽ các biệt giữ khu dung tâm và vùng ngoại ô vàn lạp y tịch lớn,
cho việc hiện thực ngoài một đồ thị phát triển mình vẫn vẫn và đồng bộ.